CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR: At a
nondescript storefront in Kyiv,
covered with plastic
against prying eyes,
a major war effort is underway.
ANDRII KOLESNYK: Oh.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
Boxes of kit
reveal a first of its kind,
fatigues designed for a mother
to be.
So was there never, Andrii,
anything for pregnant women
before?
ANDRII KOLESNYK: Never, ever.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
Now many pregnant women
are fighting the Russians?
- I'm not sure that
a lot, but there are.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
Andrii and Ksenia
are married TV journalists in
real life who now do this work.
A female friend turned
frontline sniper
told them that she was pregnant
and needed a new uniform.
They're also sending
female soldiers
smaller boots, lighter Kevlar
plates for their flak vests.
On this day, Roksolana
comes in for a new uniform.
She's in an intelligence
unit near the front
and joined up in March
totally unprepared.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
It's so valuable
to have these people who
understand that we are
tired of wearing clothes
that are three sizes too big,
she tells me.
We had no helmets, we
had old flak jackets,
we wore tracksuits and sneakers.
Now we feel that we're humans.
The Ukrainian
Ministry of Defense
says that are more
than 50,000 women
under arms, more than 5,000
of them on the front line.
Amongst them, Andrei's sister.
ANDRII KOLESNYK: She received
men's uniform, men's underwear,
everything that
designed for men.
30, 35--
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
Females also
need customized
sanitary, medical,
and humanitarian supplies.
Ksenia and Andrii have sent out
3,000 of these care packages,
they've produced 300 uniforms
and planned for at least
another 2,000, all winterized.
And then there's
this vital tool.
Oh my God.
I've never seen that.
A feminine urinary director
for women of all ages.
ANDRII KOLESNYK: Well--
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR: Basically,
they pee in that, right,
if there's no toilet?
ANDRII KOLESNYK: Not in.
They pee like men.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
Look at that.
Oh my God.
If only I'd known that in all
the years I was in the field.
And as a parting
gift, they throw
in this book on
resilience and courage
amid battle and in captivity--
- [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
Which happened to Elina
Panina five months
ago after the fall of Mariupol.
She is part of a canine
border guard unit.
And like so many of the
port city's defenders,
she'd been hunkering down in
the giant Azovstal steel plant.
She was recently released as
part of an all-female prisoner
exchange with Russia.
We meet at this pizza
bar run by vets.
Were you prepared
for life as a POW?
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR:
No I was not, she says.
And we discuss this a lot with
the other women prisoners,
that life hasn't trained
us for such an ordeal.
While in captivity though, I
said, I'll continue my service.
And I have no plans to stop.
Back at their private
procurement center,
Andrii says he
wishes he could join
his sister, father,
and brother-in-law
all at the front.
But a physical disability
means that he's not eligible.
ANDRII KOLESNYK: For
a man, it's kind of
hard to understand
that you can't go there
and your sister is there.
So I'm trying to do my
best here to help not only
my family, but the whole army.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR: And the
reviews from the battlefield
are in.
It's just amazing,
says Anastasia.
I'm happy as a child.
The uniform is ideal,
it looks great,
and the fabric is very sturdy.
Meantime, Roksolana's new
boots are made for marching
all the way back to the front.
Christiane Amanpour, CNN Kyiv.